ce sont devenus des fournitures rares
des boîtes de gants médicaux
les professionnels de santé ont de plus
en plus de mal à s'en procurer
alors pour anticiper la probable pénurie
mathilde infirmière libérale à paris a
fait des réserves malgré la flambée des
prix il ya eu des moments où par hasard
un magasin en bas de chez moi une
supérette a pu réussir à se faire
fournir des des boîtes de gand donc j'en
ai acheté c'était bien plus cher que
d'habitude
et puis quand j'en ai plus bas je me
suis fondu dans les pharmacies et là
c'était extrêmement cher en fait une
boîte de gand c'est entre 9 et 11 euros
8 euros des fois quand c'est pas cher
bon on va dire entre 8 et 11 euros les
sens gand sait encore exactement là
c'était 5 euros les 10 gants des tarifs
multiplié par cinq
mais comme les masques et les blues les
gants médicaux sont indispensables pour
prodiguer les soins à chaque fois qu'on
a chez un patient on met une paire de
gants si on fait un soin et que ces
camps font salon les enlève on les
change donc ça peut aller jusqu'à la fin
par de grands dans la journée mercredi
dernier olivier verront le ministre de
la santé a annoncé lors d'une interview
sur france 2 avoir commandé fin juillet
400 millions de gand qui devraient être
livrés dans les prochains jours mais
l'épuisement des stocks ravive la colère
des syndicats de soignants marqué par
l'insuffisance d'équipements de
protection personnelle lorsque
l'épidémie de kovy de 19 à toucher la
france il ya un manque d'anticipation et
et l'idée que ben on lorsqu'on le besoin
sera important on lancera des commandes
au niveau mondial et que ça arrivera
les leçons n'ont pas été tirées de la
première phase ne risquons de devenir
agent de transmission
faute de matériel adapté nous permettant
de ne pas transmettre ce ce virus une
chambre alors un manque de matériel qui
inquiète alors que la propagation du
coronavirus est reparti à la hausse ces
derniers jours santé publique france
révèle à une augmentation des nouveaux
cas